Now before we make some of these projects, I
want to share with you of how I learned to
program. I remember in many of my introductory computer
science classes. The instructor would start out slow and my
friends and I, we would understand everything, but then
boom, the difficulty level would skyrocket. This would make a
lot of other students inside the class feel extremely
frustrated and intimidated by code and ultimately they would quit.
We will avoid that in this class. In
this class we will make challenging projects, but at
the same time we will ensure that you're comfortable
with the learning curve. So it is in that
spirit I want to ask you, how confident
do you feel in your ability to write computer
programs? Programs like the ones we are going to
build in this class. Here are some answer choices.